[Music]
real-time geolocation is behind some of
the most awesome apps in the world such
as uber Instagram and ways to name a few
but building these features from scratch
requires a lot of complex math and
advanced data modeling but fortunately
there's tools we can use to build
features like this without any
trigonometry and we can do it in the
next few minutes if you're new here like
and subscribe and if you're serious
about building apps like this consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase com
our goal today is to use firestore and
angular google maps to build a real-time
geolocation feature so we'll be able to
say give us all the documents that are
within X kilometers of some center point
and have that query update in real time
but before we get going I have a couple
examples of real-world angular firebase
apps that use geolocation features the
first one is cipher links which was
built by an angular firebase Pro member
and is essentially a LinkedIn for coders
that allows you to find programmers
geographically based on a filtered set
of criteria and the next one is pod
mapped word which is an open source
project using angular and firebase that
allows you to locate podcasts from
around the world
check out those links in the description
but the next thing I want to talk about
is how geo queries actually work because
they're a lot different than a normal
query that you would make in firestore
so we create this fractal pattern where
we have a grid of numbers and letters
that segment the globe then we can build
out a string value by repeating this
pattern over and over again inside of
each cell so every additional character
in the string will be an additional
level of precision for the location
we're going to be saving our geohashes
as 9 characters which is precise to
about four and a half meters squared if
you go to movable-type store you can
explore the bounding boxes for different
geohashes if we want to query firestore
for all of the documents inside of a
single geo hash it's actually pretty
straightforward we can set the starting
point as the Geo hash the endpoint as
the hash plus a high Unicode character
then we can order by the property it has
that hash and then do start at end at
but here's the problem let's imagine
Kathy and Tim our next-door neighbor's
and Tim does a search within this geo
hash even though Kathy's right next door
he's only going to get results inside of
his geo hash
so to get the true results you would
have to get all of the neighboring
geohashes as well and then draw a radius
around them to find anything within that
radius and there's a bunch of other
little edge cases that you'll run into
as well which is why I decided to just
create a library that handles all this
stuff under the hood it's called geo
fire X and it uses rxjs and fire a store
to make these queries possible but don't
worry I didn't do any of the
trigonometry myself I left all that to
an awesome library called turf Jas and
it's compatible with both flat earth and
rounder theories it's also compatible
with any JavaScript framework as long as
it's using firebase in rxjs let's go
ahead and get started from a brand new
angular app and then the first thing
we'll do is install the angular Google
Maps package which is a great component
library if using Google Maps from your
firebase project you can go to the
Google cloud platform console and enable
the Google Maps JavaScript API from
there we can install angular Google Maps
in our app as well as firebase and geo
fire X now at this point if you're using
angular or ionic I would recommend using
the angular fire to library but the bare
minimum thing you need to do is just
initialize a firebase app so that should
look something like this code here then
you'll also want to initialize angular
Google Maps with your API key which you
can do here in the app module now let's
create a basic map with a GM which is
super easy the first thing we want to do
is go into our CSS and make sure we give
it a width and height of something other
than zero otherwise you won't be able to
see the map at all after that we can
just declare an AGM map component and
give it a starting the latitude and
longitude point we can also drop in a
marker and give it a latitude and
longitude as well and that will just pop
up on the map at that point what we'll
do next is loop over a collection of
documents and firestore and render them
on the map as these markers one of the
special thing is that geo Firex does is
that it saves data in a format that can
be queried in order to make geo queries
you need to have an object on the
document that contains a geo hash and a
geo point the library will format this
for you automatically but you can save
multiple geo points on a single document
so you can do geo queries against
multiple parameters so let's go ahead
and make a query against this existing
data set I'm going to go ahead and
import geo Firex as well as our firebase
app
then we can initialize GFI rx by passing
it a reference to our firebase app and
then we'll also declare a property
called points which is an observable of
the actual documents that we query there
are several variables that are needed to
make a geo query the first one is your
center point which can just be a
latitude and longitude you can create a
geo hash with the library by calling the
point method it can do a bunch of other
things like return geo JSON and
calculate distance and bearing and
things like that then the next variable
that you'll need is the radius that
you'll draw around the center point
which will always be in kilometers under
the hood the library uses Turf j s to
calculate the haversine distance which
also takes into account the curvature of
the earth and lastly we need to specify
the object that contains the geo data
because remember a single document can
have multiple geo points that can be
queried against then the next thing we
do is make a reference to the firestore
collection this is just a wrapper for
the main SDK that provides some
additional functionality for geolocation
to perform a geo query you can use
though within method that we'll take in
the center radius and field and that
returns an observable that you can just
subscribe to and it will stay in sync
with any changes that happen in real
time to that collection but because
we're using rxjs we can do this in a
little bit more of a dynamic way for
example let's say the user clicks a
button that will expand the radius to a
different value for that we could set up
the radius as a behavior subject which
itself isn't observable that can happen
new values push to it then we'll define
our observable points as the radius
behavior subject that has then switch
mapped to the actual observable geo
query and I would like to point out that
within returns a hot observable that is
cash to the last value that means you
can have multiple subscribers to it and
you will only be charged for the initial
document read so by setting this up with
a switch map we can now change the
radius and get a whole new query each
time the user clicks a button for
example we just need to call radius next
and everything else will change
reactively now we need to unwrap the
observable of our locations in angular
we can do this very conveniently with
the async pipe but in other frameworks
you'd want to call
subscribe on the observable and handle
it accordingly inside of our AGM marker
we'll do an ng for loop and we'll loop
over each point of points using the
async pipe to unwrap it because it
returns an observable array of document
data this gives us access to all of the
data on each document but it also
returns some additional metadata that's
specifically designed for building
real-time map features for example it
returns the distance and bearing that
this document was found at relative to
the query center point which can only be
figured out at runtime you might query a
collection of restaurants that are
relative to a user's current GPS
position on their phone and the query
metadata gives you the information
needed to show the distance to that
point to the user in the UI and that
will be by default on the query metadata
on the return points I have a premade
demo that I'd use for integration
testing and every point in the document
is a specific distance and bearing from
the center and the actual gray circle is
the radius of the query and if we click
on any of these points we'll also see
that query metadata which again is the
distance and bearing what's really cool
that fire store is everything is just
real time by default so imagine we have
one of these documents that are being
written to every couple of seconds as
the users position moves it will update
in the UI like we see happening here
with the blue marker but as soon as it
falls out of range
it disappears from the query and also
the UI there's a bunch of other little
features that I've added to geo by rx
specifically for working with tools like
map box and Google Maps if you find it
useful make sure to star it and please
report any issues that you encounter
when using it I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there thanks so much for
watching and I'll talk to you soon
[Music]